since the industrial revolution humans
have released over 1.5 trillion tons of
carbon dioxide or co2 into the earth's
atmosphere
in the year 2019 we were still pumping
out around 37 billion more that's 50
more than the year 2000 and almost three
times as much as 50 years ago
and it's not just co2 we're also pumping
out growing volumes of other greenhouse
gases such as methane and nitrous oxide
combining all of our greenhouse gases
we're emitting 51 billion tons of carbon
dioxide equivalents each year
and emissions keep rising
but they need to get down to zero
in recent years the consequences have
become more serious and visible almost
every year breaks some horrible record
we've had more heat waves the most
glaciers melting and the lowest amount
of ice ever recorded at the north pole
of the last 22 years 20 have been the
hottest on record
the only way to limit this rapid climate
change is to decrease our collective
emissions quickly
but although all countries agree on this
goal in principle they do not agree who
is responsible or who should bear the
heaviest load
the developed countries point at their
own efforts to reduce emissions and the
fact that the large developing countries
on the rise especially china are
currently releasing much more co2
on the other hand developing countries
argue that emissions by the west are
lifestyle emissions while for developing
countries they are survival emissions
others call rich countries hypocrites
that got rich by polluting without
restraint and now expect others not to
industrialize and stay poor
so who is responsible for climate change
and co2 emissions
and regardless of the past who needs to
do the most today
in this video we'll talk exclusively
about nation state
we'll look at the fossil fuel industry
in another video
question one of three which countries
emit the most carbon dioxide today
in 2017 humans emitted about 36 billion
tons of co2
more than 50 percent came from asia
north america and europe followed with
18 and 17
while africa south america and oceania
together only contributed 8
china is by far the world's largest
emitter with 10 billion tons of co2
every year or 27 of global emissions
it's followed by the usa with 15 percent
and the european union with around 10
percent
together this is more than half of the
world's co2 emissions
so it's clear that without the
willingness and action of these three
industrial blocks humanity will not be
able to become carbon neutral and
prevent severe climate change
next on our list is india at seven
percent
russia at five percent
japan at three percent and iran saudi
arabia south korea and canada or just
short of two percent
together with the first three the top 10
are responsible for 75 percent of global
emissions
but if we only look at the current
situation we're not getting the full
picture
question two of three which countries
have emitted the most in total
if we look at emissions throughout
history until today the outlook changes
drastically
the us and the eu both knock china off
the top spot the us is responsible for
25 percent of the world's historical
emissions emitting 400 billion tons
mostly in the 20th century
in second place is the eu at 22
china comes in third at just under 13
around half of the usa's contribution
india's contribution shrinks to 3
along with the whole of africa and south
america
the uk is responsible for one percent of
annual global emissions but takes five
percent of the historical responsibility
germany producing two percent of
emissions per year today has contributed
almost six percent as much as the whole
of africa and south america combined
so the narrative that rapid climate
change is really the responsibility of
the developing world is hard to defend
if facts matter to you
but this is still not the whole story
because focusing on countries mixes two
things population numbers and total
emissions
if a country has more people in general
its emissions are of course higher
things look very different if we look at
individuals like you dear viewer
question three of three
which countries emit the most carbon
dioxide per person
the average human is responsible for
around 5 tons of co2 each year
but averages can be misleading
the countries with the largest co2
emissions per person are some of the
world's major oil and gas producers
in 2017 qatar had the highest emissions
at a hefty 49 tonnes per person followed
by trinidad and tobago kuwait the united
arab emirates brunei bahrain and saudi
arabia
but those are outliers
australians have one of the highest
carbon footprints per person
17 tons a year
that's more than triple the global
average and slightly more than the
average u.s american and canadian at 16
tons
the germans do a little better at close
to 10 tonnes but this is still twice the
global average
china may be the world's largest emitter
but it's also the world's most populous
country with over 1.4 billion people
18.5 percent of the world population
per person it's above average at seven
tons
historically co2 emissions have been
closely tied to a high standard of
living
wealth is one of the strongest
indicators of our carbon footprint
because as we move from poor to rich we
gain access to electricity heating air
conditioning lighting modern cooking
cars or planes smartphones computers and
interact with people across the world
online
the enormous rise of china's co2
emissions is coupled with the greatest
reduction of poverty in history
if we order co2 emissions by income we
see that the richest half of countries
are responsible for 86 percent of global
emissions and the bottom half for only
14 percent
the average german emits more than five
times as much as the average indian
in just 2.3 days the average american
emits as much as the average nigerian in
a year
and not only that the harsh reality is
that it's the countries that contribute
least to the problem that stand to lose
the most from rapid climate change
the developing world will be hit the
hardest
the consequences could be food
insecurity conflicts over resources
harsher and more frequent natural
disasters and large climate refugee
movements
question four
of three
so who should take responsibility
many of today's richest countries are in
a convenient position
they have become rich over centuries of
fossil fuel burning and industrial
production
they have a large historical footprint
and their wealth means they still emit a
lot per person
but their country's annual emissions are
now dwarfed by other countries because
the giant that is china is finally
catching up and other giants like india
are on their way
many germans for example wonder how if
germany only accounts for two percent of
yearly emissions it can have a
meaningful impact on reducing emissions
the answer is simple for one the richest
countries have the resources highly
educated workforces and technology to
develop low-cost low-carbon solutions
and spread them around the world
if we don't want poorer countries to
become as fossil fuel dependent as we
are we need low carbon technology to be
cheap and available
and we're getting there the cost of
renewables is falling quickly and a
variety of solutions are on the horizon
for many different sectors
but it needs to happen much faster
if the rich countries of the west decide
to seriously tackle rapid climate change
the rest of the world would follow
because it has no choice
just like when the european union
enforced energy efficiency standards for
technology the rest of the world adopted
them too because they wanted to be able
to continue trading with the block
still this doesn't absolve others of
their responsibility
china is the largest co2 emitter today
and it's china's responsibility to grow
in a way that will make it possible to
transition to a zero-carbon world in
time
others acting irresponsibly yesterday is
a horrible excuse for repeating the same
mistakes today
climate change is a global problem and
no country alone can fix it
working out who's responsible is not as
simple as it seems and in a way it's a
daft question but one that has played
international politics for decades
in the end it's pretty simple
everybody needs to do the best they can
and right now we are all not doing that
but we can begin
today
this video is part of a series about
climate change supported by breakthrough
energy a coalition founded by bill gates
that's working to expand clean energy
investment and support the innovations
that will lead the world to net zero
carbon emissions also a special thanks
to the team at our world in data for
helping us out with data and research
[Music]
you